One way that an attacker can create
problems for you and all of your users
is to prevent your systems from working
at all. We refer to this as a denial of
service attack. The attacker is forcing
a particular service to fail and
therefore people cannot access that
service to perform their work. A very
simplified form of a denial of service
is an attacker that overwhelms the
capability of a particular server. So
instead of having a few people access a
server at a time, an attacker might have
hundreds or thousands of devices trying
to access a system simultaneously.
Or the attacker may have found a
particular combination of events that
causes the system to fail. This might be
a vulnerability within software or it
might be a design failure in the system.
Regardless of the process used, the
result is the same. the system is
unavailable and anyone who wants to
access the service will find that the
service is no longer accessible.
Sometimes the denial of service is for
the technical people to spend their time
trying to resolve the denial of service
issue while at the same time other
attackers are trying to take advantage
of vulnerabilities with completely
unrelated systems. And although we may
be thinking that a denial of service is
relatively complex and it involves a lot
of different resources, the reality is
that a denial of service can be
relatively simple. For example, if
somebody goes to the back of a building
and turns off the main power, that will
certainly be a denial of service.
Sometimes a denial of service or a DOSs
is something that we do to ourselves, an
unintended situation that was caused by
something that we did inside of our own
network. For example, if you're
connecting different switches together
and you accidentally connect two
switches together with two separate
cables, you'll create a loop on the
switch network, assuming that you're not
already running spanning tree protocol.
But if you're not running spanning tree,
you'll find that your network will stop
working almost immediately because
you've created a network denial of
service. Or maybe you're at a remote
location that has limited bandwidth to
the internet, but you need to download a
Linux distribution. And by doing that,
you're now taking up all of the
available bandwidth over that very small
internet connection. Anyone else who
needs to perform any type of function to
the internet may find that it's too slow
to access. And so you've created a
bandwidth related denial of service. And
I've been part of a denial of service
that involved water. We had a coffee
machine on the seventh floor that had a
water supply and that water supply
connection broke on a Friday afternoon.
No one was in the building over the
weekend and the water seeped down past
the sixth floor, the fifth floor, and
finally hit the data center on the
fourth floor. Fortunately, not a lot of
systems were affected, but there were
some outages caused by this water-based
denial of service.
Attackers that are using a denial of
service are not commonly attacking with
a single system. Instead, they will use
multiple systems that are often located
around the world. We refer to this as a
distributed denial of service or a DDoS.
Advanced forms of a DDoS might involve
an entire botnet. There might be
millions of devices infected with the
same malware around the world. And that
malware allows the attacker to send
messages to all of these devices and
have them perform different functions.
Imagine having 3.6 million devices
around the world infected with the Zeus
botnet. The people that are managing
that botnet can now tell all 3.6 million
devices to begin attacking one single
device on the internet. The worst part
is that the people who are participating
in this botnet may have no idea it's
even occurring. The botnet is running in
the background of people's computers and
those machines are effectively zombies.
They are under the control of the person
running the botnet while at the same
time still acting as the main computing
system for that user.
Some types of DOS attacks can be
identified by the information inside of
a packet. And if all of those packets
are very similar, you may be able to
filter that packet at your firewall.
Some internet service providers have
DDoS prevention systems in the core of
their internet service provider network.
So your ISP may be able to enable that
DDoS mitigation and prevent that traffic
from reaching your local network. And
some companies on the internet
specialize in preventing these types of
attacks. A good example is the reverse
proxy capabilities at Cloudflare where a
customer can turn on DDoS prevention and
stop all of those attacks from reaching
their local servers.